بعد سنوات طويله من العمل في ورشه لتصنيع
الاثاث يشتكي فتحي من نقص العاملين الشباب
فاليوم باتت فئه لا باس بها من ارباب
العمل في تركيا تتحدث عن طبيعات اقتصاديه
سلبيه على القطاع المهني
فتتاخر اعمالنا عند انتعاش السوق الشباب
لا يفضلون القطاعات المهنيه ونقصد العامله
يعني تراجع الانتاج
ترى الحكومه في مراكز التدريب المهني حلا
لمشكله العماله التي يتلقى الطلاب فيها
تعليم النظريا وعمليا مقابل اجر مدفوع
وتؤكد وزاره التعليم ارتفاعه عدد المقبلين
على تلك المراكز مع وصول عدد المسجلين في
نوفمبر الماضي الى مليون و 33,000
دبلومه
الاقتصاديه مقابل الدروس التطبيقيه
وسينخرط هؤلاء في سوق العمل
ومع ذلك ثم تساؤلات عن اسباب تراجع الايدي
العامله رغما انخفاض نسبه البطاله من اكثر
من 22 في المئه الى نحو عشره في المئه في
اكتوبر الماضي بحسب هيئه الاحصاء الرسميه
هجره الداخليه
يقول اصحاب الورشات ان اتجاه الطلاب نحو
الثانويه العامه ومنها الى الجامعات وقف
في وجه تنشئه جيل من المهنيين ولذلك يحاول
المعنيون تسهيل دخول طلاب الثانويه
المهنيه للتخصصات الجامعيه ذات الصله
النظام التعليمي ويع
ول الثانويه
المهدومه من الحكومه على ذلك يعزز
الاقتصاد فرح زمن شوقي الجزيره انقره